Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous, je m’appelle
Dantès Daï Liang.
Daï, porter
Liang, la lumière.
Daï Liang, qui porte la lumière,
c’est mon nom chinois.
En fait, j'ai appris le mandarin
à l'âge de onze ans.
J’ai voulu apprendre le chinois mandarin,
parce que j’avais envie d’être différent.
Et à onze ans, en France,
pour être différent -
il y a plein de solutions, j’imagine -
mais pour moi, c’était d’apprendre
une langue complètement différente
de ce qu’on aurait pu
apprendre à l’époque : l’anglais,
l’allemand, l’italien.
Apprendre le chinois mandarin.
Le chinois mandarin,
c’est quand même une langue différente.
Par exemple, on ne dit pas :
« Caméléon ».
On dit :
« un dragon qui change de couleur ».
On ne dit pas : « un ordinateur »,
on dit : « un cerveau électrique ».
On ne dit pas : « un train »,
on dit :
« un véhicule de feu ».
Le chinois mandarin.
Oui, c'est vrai que c'était différent.
La culture aussi,
elle est vraiment différente.
La manière de voir le passé,
le présent, l’avenir,
les opinions sur, peut-être,
ce qu’il peut se passer dans le monde,
c’est très différent.
Et puis, bien sûr, il y a la rencontre
avec les personnages un peu particuliers.
Par exemple, en 1995, j’avais 17 ans,
je suis allé pour la première fois
en Chine, à Pékin,
et j’ai rencontré Cui Jian.
C’est le pionnier du rock chinois,
c’est le musicien chinois
qui a introduit la musique rock en Chine.
Moi, à 17 ans, j’écoutais beaucoup
Oasis, le groupe anglais.
J'écoutais aussi Jean-Jacques Goldman.
J'écoutais Jean-Michel Jarre.
Mais quand j’ai débarqué à Pékin
lors de la répétition de Cui Jian -
il m’avait invité, mes camarades et moi -
j’ai découvert la musique
rock à la chinoise.
Il y avait des basses, des batteries,
il y avait une guitare électrique.
Mais il y avait aussi du harout,
une vielle à deux cordes.
Il y avait aussi un guqin.
Et il y avait aussi un xiao, c’était
l’instrument de prédilection de Cui Jian.
Il jouait de la trompette chinoise.
La rencontre avec Cui Jian,
le pionnier du rock chinois.
Ma première rencontre, c’était
la rencontre avec la culture chinoise,
avec la langue chinoise, avec la Chine.
Cette connaissance, cette rencontre
avec cette connaissance,
avec cet apprentissage
de cette connaissance,
elle a changé ma vie.
Elle a orienté ma vie.
Vous, est-ce que vous avez,
dans votre vie,
rencontré une connaissance comme ça ?
Est-ce que vous avez eu accès
à une connaissance
qui a changé votre vie ?
Ma deuxième rencontre, c’est la rencontre
avec ma créativité, avec moi-même.
En fait, en l’an 2000,
j’ai passé un an à Shanghai.
Et j’ai eu une idée un peu particulière,
en tout cas pour l’époque,
c’était de composer
un album en mandarin.
Alors, il faut replacer
quand même le contexte.
Il y a 20, 25 ans, apprendre le mandarin
en France et en Europe,
c’était quand même
quelque chose de très bizarre.
Pour beaucoup de gens,
ça ne servait à rien.
Pour mon propre père.
apprendre le mandarin,
ça ne servait à rien.
Valait mieux apprendre l'anglais
et l'allemand.
Vous imaginez investir dans la production
d’un disque tout en mandarin ?
D’ailleurs, mon coproducteur,
qui se trouvait à Lyon à l’époque,
à côté de Lyon, me disait :
« OK, moi je veux bien coproduire avec toi
un album en français, mais en mandarin !
À quoi ça va nous servir ? »
Et pourtant, cet album, il est sorti.
On peut peut-être montrer l’image…
Il est sorti et c’était assez
impressionnant pour moi
de voir cette créativité,
cette création, dans le réel.
Maintenant, la question,
c’était de savoir ce que
ça allait donner en Chine.
Est-ce que c’était juste
une vision de l’esprit ?
Ou est-ce que c’était quelque chose
qui pourrait avoir une forme…
quelque chose d’important,
quelque chose qui aurait de la valeur
dans un pays si lointain comme la Chine ?
Et là, c’est ma troisième rencontre.
Ma troisième rencontre,
c’est la rencontre avec le public chinois.
Parce que, en 2004, je suis allé
m’installer à Shanghai.
Et là, j’ai fait le tour des grandes
maisons de disques en Chine :
Canton, Shanghai, Pékin.
Et les directeurs de maison
de disques m’ont tous dit la même chose :
« Daï Liang ! -
je vous rappelle, c’est mon nom chinois,
Daï Liang -
Ton idée est quand même sympa.
On n’a pas comme ça d’Occidentaux,
de Français, qui écrit, qui compose
et qui chante en mandarin. »
Pour moi, c'était un peu une validation
de cette créativité dans le réel.
Mais ma plus belle des rencontres en fait,
à cette époque, quand j’ai rencontré
le public chinois,
c’était en 2005 où j’ai pu chanter
pour la première fois
mon titre en chinois
qui s’appelle [chinois]
qui veut dire « Je suis arrivé
en Chine en l’an 2000 ».
Et je me suis aperçu
qu’en fait, avec cette chanson,
je pouvais toucher le cœur
de dizaines, de centaines, de milliers,
peut-être plus, de personnes qui n’avaient
aucun lien avec ma propre culture.
On était en 2005, février 2005,
à la télévision de Pékin,
avec 400 millions de téléspectateurs.
Je vais vous chanter ce titre.
(Applaudissements)
On remercie Martin pour la technique.
(Musique)
(Chante)
(Applaudissements)
[En chinois]
Cette première chanson du français
qui écrit et chante en chinois.
Et vous, est-ce que vous avez
trouvé votre public ?
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré
votre public ?
Ma dernière rencontre,
c’est la rencontre avec les gens
qui me ressemblent et qui me soutiennent.
Parce que quand on a atteint
une partie de ses rêves,
ces rêves,
ce dont on a envie, c’est que ça continue.
Et là, je me suis aperçu
que pour que ça continue,
il fallait qu’il y ait des gens qui nous
soutiennent et qui nous ressemblent.
Alors pour moi, les gens
qui me ressemblent,
ce sont des gens
qui aiment l’interculturalité,
qui aiment et jouent avec les cultures,
qui ne voient pas de barrières,
qui ne voient pas de frontières.
Les gens qui me soutiennent,
ce sont des gens
qui ont un esprit pionnier.
Les gens qui aiment voir des choses,
alors que finalement,
la plupart des gens autour d’eux
ne les voient pas.
Un peu comme à l’époque quand j’apprenais
le chinois à onze ans en France
et que la plupart des gens trouvaient
que ça n’avait pas de valeur.
Un peu comme lorsque j’ai enregistré
cet album en 2003 en France en mandarin,
et que beaucoup trouvaient
qu’il n’y avait pas vraiment
de sens à tout ça.
Pour terminer, je vais chanter un titre
que j’ai l’habitude de jouer en Chine
quand les médias chinois eux aussi
me posent des questions :
« Qu’est-ce que tu fais,
Daï Liang, toi, en Chine ?
Qu’est-ce que tu fais toutes ces années ?
Pourquoi tu es en Chine ? »
Plutôt que de répondre en faisant un talk,
je réponds à ces questions
avec une chanson qui s’appelle
[Chinois].
Ça veut dire « Français de Chine ».
Et peut-être qu’après cette chanson, vous
comprendrez un petit peu mieux pourquoi
je suis le Français qui écrit
et chante en chinois.
On redemande à Martin, s'il te plaît.
(Musique)
(Chante en chinois)
(Applaudissements)
Merci à tous.